[Music]
thank you
here in this video we will rank the top
10 most powerful dragons from House of
the dragon and Game of Thrones let's
just say that size is a big factor to
power in this case but there are also
other things that determine how strong a
dragon is so let's get to it
at number 10 we have sea smoke sea smoke
was a silver gray dragon with pale skin
during the dance he was of fighting size
but he was still a young dragon nimbler
in the air than his older brothers he
was comparable in size to Cesarion who
was about three times smaller than Verma
Thor and not nearly as terrifying sea
smoke participated in many battles
during the dance and even before it he
was a beta to melees but later on became
a dragon that led armies to war he even
challenged and fought wormuthor to the
death causing the bigger dragon to also
die due to Grievous wounds being
inflicted on him
number nine Regal we initially had
thoughts to put in Cyrax in the ninth
spot but the she Dragon didn't have any
fights to her name nor was she in any
significant battle in the dance of the
Dragons so rhaegar was chosen for the
top 10. rhaegar was one of Danny's
dragons smaller than drogon and of the
same size as viserion maybe he was a bit
more powerful than viserion but he was
then later proved to be weaker than the
undead white viserion which had a night
King's magic in him rhaegar fought
against viserion and survived due to
drogon's assistance
number eight white viserion while being
large and Powerful by the seventh season
of Game of Thrones rhaegar and viseria
were pretty much the same in size and
strength at the same time being weaker
than drogon but when viserion was killed
and revived by the ninth King
his Undead form possessed a more
powerful demeanor white viserion could
now go toe-to-toe with drogon and even
had drogon's ass in a fair or one-on-one
fight as he has unlimited stamina and
ferocity but then again drogon was
bigger and more intelligent than the
Drone undead dragon
number seven drogon drogon is one of
dany's dragons his name after Daenerys
targaryen's late husband Carl Drogo he
is thought to be Valerian the black
dreads reincarnation his flame is black
with red flashes and the warmth of his
head can be felt from 30 feet away his
wing flap sounds like a Thunderclap he
bleeds blood that is black in color the
only test of strength for him was
surviving a scorpion Vault and managing
to defeat the undead white viserion in a
battle over Winterfell although the
fight would have been more even if
rhaegar wasn't there
number six on fire he was the most
beautiful dragon ever seen in the known
world according to Arch maester gildane
but he wasn't just beautiful he was also
deadly as hell Sunfire survived the Bell
against melees in the Rook rest but that
was also in part due to Vega's
assistance sunfai also killed an older
Greg host which was a wild dragon in
Dragonstone and lastly as the earlier
battles crippled him even to a point
where he wasn't able to fly properly he
was still deadly that even in a state of
handicapness he still managed to kill a
younger and more Nimble Moon Dancer
number five melees melees was considered
one of westeros's fastest dragons easily
outpacing caraxis and Vega melees though
had grown Lazy by 129 AC but she was
still terrifyingly fast when aroused
melees was a proud reserved and wise
dragon and very experienced in battle in
a final battle she was ambushed and
fought against two other dragons Vega
and Sunfire Arch Master gildane believed
that melees had a chance of surviving a
battle against the older Vega alone but
not against vegar and Sunfire combined
even though melees initially had the
upper hand and was able to close her jaw
around sunfire's neck it wasn't until
Vega fell upon them causing her to die
due to the fall
number four galaxies
he was bright red massive and slender he
was fearsome for mobile and experienced
in battle caraxis was roughly half the
size of the mass of Vega during the
dance of the Dragons the dragon Keepers
dubbed him as the blood worm because he
was the most fearsome of the Dragon bits
young dragons karaxi's most deadliest
battle was against Vega herself and even
though physically outmatched he did
manage to kill Vega by ripping out her
throat as they fell from the air into
the God's eye Lake caraxis even managed
to come out of the lake alive but then
died not long after due to his wounds as
his abdomen has been ripped open and one
of his wings were missing
number three vegar according to Jerry
Lannister she was large enough to
swallow a horse down her throat Vega's
breath was said to be so hot that it
could melt a knight's armor and cook him
from inside Vega was a hardened Survivor
of 100 Battles by the time of the dance
of the dragons and had grown almost as
large as valerion and was the oldest and
largest dragon in Westeros at that time
with no other living dragon that could
compete with her in terms of size or
strength well except for one maybe or
this one could be a tie for second place
number two Verma Thor as you can see
from the last episode of House of the
Dragon when Damon realizes that Vega
would be a great problem he made a move
to awaken and let loose the bronze
Theory vormthar this Dragon was the
third largest and not far away in size
from Vega herself and he is still also
way younger around 80 years younger than
Vega meaning that vermuthor is less
sluggish and more agile in the air
against the giant dragon he was able to
kill two dragons in the bell of
dumbleton as well as scores of knights
sent to slay him while he was asleep
imagine being ambushed and still
managing to kill all the enemies but
then at the cause of his own life as
well
and number one valerion also known as
the black dread he was the largest and
most powerful Dragon in the universe of
A Song of Ice and Fire And even though
we have never gotten the chance to see
him live in action his deeds were enough
even Vega plays second fiddle to him
Valerian had black scales and reddish
tinted Wings his fire was said to be
black with red swirls here and there
when he was at his most powerful his
Flames could melt steel and stone and
fused sand into glass his teeth were as
long as swords and his Jaws were large
enough to swallow a hairy Mammoth hole
and so that's it I hope you have enjoyed
watching this video do hit the like
button for support and subscribe but
most of all smash that Bell icon for
regular updates of new videos right here
on this channel to the next one take
care fam